eu eu
o pessoal do canibal lado pessoal do que
falar andar com esse timinho saiu
campeão vamos lá então como mv provide
de hoje há muita voz dança e pensei
comigo pensei que me cobra menos uma
vítima temos um subproduto folhas temos
um tubo respirador cinco metros a silver
tape tarde uma máquina de fumaça e um
balão gigante
[Risadas]
[Aplausos]
o problema não está na máquina de fumaça
ainda funciona a cair nas finais
nacionais
vamos ver se o produto foi responsável
também
pode parecer que não mas esta coisinha
pequena tem muita potência olha ele aí
eu eu eu eu um trapiche no bolão cérebro
e como funcionará o mecanismo que como
vocês devem calcular nem sempre está por
aí
supra eu tenho que chutar do álbum lá né
não estou em fim e não se falar daqui
que é preciso muito nós vamos colocar a
nossa fumaça vamos ver se funciona
também hora
agora é só ligar ao mesmo tempo em 31
vai meu deus vou pegar o carro que está
tudo bem mas quero ver essa máquina faz
muito barulho e então usar o nosso todos
os jogadores e colocar aqui ea ponta do
balão nesta ponta
vamos ver se funciona 32 culpa sucesso
no domingo sucesso
o be vai funcionar e facebook estão
sobretudo com a fifa
o meu bebê e meu bebê estava lá fora
sozinho sem um dono nem é fácil
ae um golo limpo porque as brincadeiras
da época vamos estar aqui uma coisa
quero ver como é que os infiéis da
fumaça
três passos o que é que se passa o que é
isso aqui não está muito a tua do bob s
um raio na fuga sérgio guerra pé agora o
que tenho que fazer
[Música]
olá pessoal já está tudo pronto agora
vamos fazer o quarto do ano vamos
confirmar se voltará a dormir vamos
confirmar tudo bem e já já vou colocar
uma câmera dentro do quarto de leo e
outra fora que é pra vocês verem a minha
reação e eu acabei para um estrondo
gigantones deixa o vosso likes e banana
muita pena para lá
[Música]
ok só tem de continuar com o plano agora
é montar tudo e vou tentar ficar tipo
mais tensão triplo até lá o quarto
[Música]
o
[Aplausos]
[Risadas]
vamos tentar fazer um bom campeonato
troika
[Música]
não tenha manhã que tudo cansado eu sei
que o senhor só de itajá fazer isso
nelson às três da tarde 11 12 e tal
montada não eu tenho que descansar e
depois é como voltar né país nesta casa
temos horários net sobre janela da casa
do sol nascente do sol devem ver que eu
não consegui descansar hoje
agora claro meu amigo transplantar eu
preciso ir até o dia que eu faço agora
ele pô
rocha era uma rocha mais gostoso não
quer uma mesma linha uma faixa roxa
louco só quero saber à noite tanto meu
deus se imprimir meu tipo não chega
tocha a fazer esse cenas de the burning
jovem só falar que eu acusou pepe mas o
que parece agora joguei
o show é só resultam aproveitamento eu
que fora só que fora do sistema muito
mas não deve cair entre muito louco só
se quiserem mais prático entendem o que
é que vocês querem que eu faça aqui o
pessoal da casa já sabem deixei muito
aqui no espírito pra ajudar e por criar
o canal isso é muito importante mesmo
espectro de um estado fiquei mais
aproximar